pushing time away is the biography of
David Oppenheim classical scholar and
grandfather of the author Peter Singer
mr. singer reconstructed his
grandfather's life from his days as a
member of the inner circle of Sigmund
Freud to his death in a concentration
camp in 1943 this talk from Wordsworth
books in Cambridge Massachusetts is just
under an hour thank you very much for
that generous introduction
indeed I wanted to begin by saying a
little picked up the theme about the
difference between this book and the
other books that I've written about and
worked on and asked why did I write this
book given that my other books have
generally been on major moral issues
that have seemed to me very urgent
issues like Animal Liberation the way we
treat animals questions in bioethics
about life and death decision making or
about new artificial reproductive
technology or topics like my previous
book before this one one world about
globalization and ethics these are all
major questions and to turn from that to
writing about my own grandfather who
while I think an interesting person and
a thinker definitely of his own and
intellectual I could not claim was you
know the neglected genius of the 20th
century or anything of that sort so why
take the time from the other issues of
the day and certainly there's no lack of
pressing issues all around us to focus
on my grandfather well I suppose there
were a number of personal reasons why I
wanted to do this one is that I wanted
to get to know my grandfather I never
did know my grandfather because he was a
victim of the Nazis and died in 1943
three years before I was born
so I couldn't get to know him and in
some sense I suppose I Oh
felt I was robbed of three of my four
grandparents anyway who I did not know
because they were victims of the Nazis
and because this particular grandparent
my mother's father had written quite
extensively had published a number of
articles and one book and because I knew
that some letters that he'd written had
survived I thought one day I want to
read all that I want to get to know it
but I kept postponing it I wasn't in a
great hurry to do so I always seemed to
have more interesting urgent important
things to do until at some stage in the
mid-1990s I guess I was prompted to do
so partly by the thought that those who
knew him were now themselves dying or
the case of my mother for example
developing Alzheimer's so that she could
no longer really tell me about him and
partly also prompted by the fact that
some of the letters that he wrote to my
parents after they left Vienna they left
Vienna in 1938 and came to Australia
some of those letters were published in
an in a book published in Austria and
that made them more accessible because
all those that were published more
accessible because one of the
difficulties in reading them was not
simply that they were in German which I
can cope with but that they were in very
tiny handwrite handwriting on very thin
sheets of paper written on both sides
which did make them extremely difficult
to read so that got me a little more
interested in it and eventually I just
said well the time has come I've got a
either do this or never do it that still
was not a decision actually to write a
book about my grandfather it was a
decision to spend the time getting to
know more about my grandfather getting
to try to understand such questions as
why he and my other grandparents did not
leave Austria when my parents did
basically that means as soon as they
could get a visa to go somewhere
after the Nazis marched in and
you know these were things that I wanted
to know for myself and perhaps to pass
down to my children so that the family
history would not be lost but was there
a book in in this I really wasn't sure
then a couple of things happen one was
to my surprise I discovered not only
that there were letters existing from
this period after my parents had left
Vienna in not basically from 1938 to the
time when correspondence stopped in it
faded away basically in 1940 but there
was still one or two letters I think as
late as 41 not only that there were
those letters but also I found and
pretty much literally they fell on my
head when I was going through my aunt's
apartment letters that my grandfather
had written to my grandmother before
they were married a set of over a
hundred letters written from 1904 to
1906 only one side of the correspondence
unfortunately my grandmother's replies
were not preserved but this opened up a
whole new window into what my
grandparents were like at a very early
period of their lives in their in their
20s and this proved to be actually quite
a remarkable correspondence because it
was a very intimate and personal
correspondence and I'll perhaps read you
just a tiny bit to give you a glimpse of
that before I finish so that was one
thing that gave me the sense that I can
actually get to know my grandfather as a
human being not just as a scholar and
writer at this early stage of his life
then also I found a variety of other
things that filled in some of the gaps
my grandfather was a member of Freud's
Wednesday circle it's very fitting that
we have the introductory lectures on
psychoanalysis and Freud looking over my
shoulder but he might not approve
because although my grandfather was a
member of his circle
for some time and actually co-authored a
manuscript with him a manuscript that
had a curious fate later on when the
first big schism occurred in Freud's
circle the schism between Freud and his
leading follower at that time Alfred
Adler
my grandfather sided with Adler and
Freud never again spoke to ARLA or any
of those who took his side in that
dispute he was not a forgiving man in
that sort of matter so the minutes of
the Freud year fraud circle are
preserved and I was able to read my
grandfather's comments in those
discussions and the minutes and one or
two papers that he presented as well and
of course there was the manuscript that
he wrote with Freud which was not
published in his lifetime because of
that split but which remained apparently
in his hands and must he must have
preserved that all during the subsequent
years the manuscript dates from 1911 he
must have preserved that all during the
subsequent years in Vienna until knowing
that he was faced with deportation in
1942 he must have given it together with
other papers of his and the letters that
I refer to the early letters to some
trusted non-jewish friend in Vienna and
they had many of them who remained loyal
and faithful to them visiting them in
their apartment during the Nazi period
so he must have given it to to these
papers to some of them and because my
grandmother my mother's mother
miraculously survived she was then able
to return to Vienna and retrieve the
letters and the papers and the Freud up
and home manuscript so she didn't still
didn't want to publish it as long as she
was alive but after she died in 1955 my
aren't her younger daughter sold it as
she thought anyway to the Freud archives
who subsequently published it and it is
now included in the standard edition of
Freud's works however when I tried to
find it in the collection of the Freud
archives which is in the Library of
Congress's manuscript division I found
only a photocopy of it and when I
followed this up I was told in fact that
it had not been sold to the Freud
archives but had been privately
purchased I can only say that that is
very difficult to reconcile with the
correspondence that I still have between
my aunt and the Freud archives in which
they offer a certain sum of money and
she accepts that sum for the manuscript
and then sends it to them so there was I
think some rather peculiar dealings
going on which led to it being in
private hands as far as I can tell
be that as it may this started to round
out the possibility of a book about my
grandfather but there was also a larger
issue it seemed to me that did make it
worth presenting to a wider audience
quite apart from the various human
interest aspects and that is the
question of the fact that during my
grandfather's life the part of the world
in which he lived went from this period
that was described to you of a very high
point in civilization in culture a
remarkable moment in which there was a
great ferment of ideas and a strong
sense of progress towards more civilized
more humanist values that is the Vienna
of before the war and to some extent
still for a brief period after the first
world war and then fell away to the
depths of barbarism in which my
grandfather died and I think that there
are questions to be asked about what
does that say about the fragility of our
values the fragility of civilization and
our ability to protect those values or
indeed even to force
accurately their decline because of
course was the fact that my grandfather
did not foresee quite the depths to
which Nazism would lead that meant that
he was not sufficiently motivated at
least early on to take the steps that
would have been necessary to leave
nazi-occupied Austria in time so I felt
that there were many things that could
be brought together in this book that
would make it something that was larger
than simply a question of me getting to
know my grandfather although I think
very often those personal stories also
have their fascination so what I'd like
to do just briefly before opening up to
questions is is read you I put a brief
passage or two which will maybe give you
a little bit of the book the flavor of
the book it opens with a prologue dated
January 1997 a freezing fog hangs over
Vienna softening the light of the street
lamps there's snow on the ground and the
bare branches of the trees are tipped
with frost I am walking down ports along
Gaza a Broad Street in Vienna's ninth
district it is 7:00 p.m. the street is
quiet for most people prefer not to
drive in this weather the roads are too
slick the street is lined with buildings
four or five stories high they've
changed little since the days before the
First World War when Vienna was one of
the great cities of the world the
capital of the austro-hungarian Empire
and then Empire was a major power
surpassed only by Russia in the extent
of the European territory over which it
ruled its land spread northeast as far
as what is now Ukraine east over today's
Czech and Slovak Republic's and
southeast through Hungary Slovenia
Croatia and Bosnia to the fateful city
of Sarajevo all of my grandparents lived
in the city then I knew only my mother's
mother Amalia up and home the sole
survivor of the tragedy that overwhelmed
Vienna's Jews after the Nazi annexation
of Austria but tonight pushing away
his tire at the time that has passed
since that calamity I will begin to get
to know one other grandparent in a
backpack I'm carrying a stack of papers
they must weigh about 15 pounds by and
about my mother's mother my sorry my
mother's father David up and home
included in this treasure trove of
family history are more than a hundred
letters my grandparents wrote to my
parents Cora and own singer and to my
mother's sister then Dora stopping home
after they left for Australia in 1938
I've just collected them from dr. Adolf
guys para director of the library of the
State Archives of Vienna who last year
published some of them in a book called
David an stoppin home fun Orem Troy and
farted Arvid the title means the
subtitle means from your faithful father
David and is the way in which my
grandfather closed his letters at the
end of ports along Gough gasa I cross
beg you sir just a few doors from number
19 where Sigmund Freud had his home and
his consulting rooms earlier in the day
seeking traces of my grandfather I had
visited Freud's rooms now a museum here
the famed Wednesday group more formally
known as the Vienna psychoanalytical
Society met my grandfather became a
member of the group in January 1910 and
attended its meetings for nearly two
years on April the 20th 1910 his 29th
birthday he gave a presentation entitled
suicide in childhood to a group of 16
people including Freud and most of the
regular members of the society his paper
was a great success stimulating so
lively a conversation that the group
voted to publish a pamphlet including
David's talk and the ensuing discussion
quite a birthday present for a young
high school teacher as I left Freud's
rooms I imagine my grandfather walking
down those same steps in a state of
elation as a talented young scholar with
him Freud was eager to collaborate he
appeared to have a bright future ahead
of him yet within 19 months my
grandfather had parted from Freud
following instead the first of the great
heretics of psychoanalysis Alfred Adler
in opposition to Freud's insistence on
unconscious sexual desire
as the key to understanding human
behavior I'll develop the idea of the
inferiority complex and saw the drive to
gain power as a compensation for a sense
of inferiority as more significant why I
wondered did David take the decision to
side with our dealer knowing that this
must mean the end of all further contact
with Freud another man also celebrated
his birthday in Vienna on that April
20th 1910 his prospects were not so good
he was living in a shelter set up by the
municipal government to provide beds for
single men at a token cost on the
fringes of the city having twice failed
the entrance test to Vienna's Academy of
Fine Arts he was making a meager living
painting postcards in watercolours a
friend sold them for a few pennies in
taverns and cafes here on the day my
grandfather had his 29th birthday this
second-rate painter turned 21
while my grandfather was trying through
his work with Freud and then idler to
understand the springs of human nature
the would-be artist had his own shrewd
insights into the yearnings of millions
of Germans and Austrians his fiercely
nationalist and anti-semitic aims were
diametrically at odds with my
grandfather's hopes for the spread of a
universal recognition of our common
humanity but in 1910 the improbable
intersection of the lives of Alfred
Hitler and David oppan home lay many
years ahead let me just read you a
little bit about the letters that I
mentioned from the first the first
period though my mother and aunt had
often told me stories about their
parents I had never been told how they
met or became close the letters I had
found in David's apartment gave me once
I found someone who could help me read
David's near impossible script a
startling answer the correspondence
began in the summer of 1904 when David
was 23 and Amalia three years older they
were both students at the University of
Vienna he was studying classics and she
math and physics and they both came from
highly educated Moravian Jewish families
David was lodging with an aunt but
Amalia lived with her mother in Vienna
father having died nine years earlier
the first letter in the correspondence
was mystifying
it seemed that Imani had offered to
mediate in some situation relating to a
boy but David had thought it best not to
take up her offer
for fear that the entry of a third
person would cause the boy to shy off
there is a reference to eros the Greek
god of love and an offer if all goes
well to send Amalia quote the letters
that I wrote when mad what could that
mean in a second letter written a month
later David tells Amalia that on
returning home after a three-week trip
to Italy he found quote the letters that
my cousin demanded of Victor and that he
was sending them to Amalia together with
two letters he had himself written the
victor was evidently the boy referred to
in the first letter to help Amalia
understand the letters
David included some explanatory notes if
they were helpful to Amalia they were
nothing short of astounding to me and
are quite short passage the entire
correspondence that is David referring
to the correspondence with Victor
extends over four years 1900 to 1904 the
first letter of any significance that I
wrote to Victor is unfortunately missing
it was a monstrous piece of writing in
the style of a final year high school
student in it I told him a story of how
we had become acquainted two years
previously in almonds and the impression
that he had made on him I gave him clear
signs that led him to understand as I
believed that I was in love with him I
thought there was an interesting letter
to begin a relationship that led to the
marriage of my grandparents and to the
procreation of my mother and aunt and I
won't read you more but the letters do
complain contain a fairly complete
account I think of the beginning and
nature of that relationship well I do
want to leave you some time for
questions but I'll just read a little
more about the other period that is
discussed in the book the period
well one of the periods the period at
the end after the Nazi Angelus in the
moral darkness of Nazi Vienna a few
non-jewish visitors defied the
propaganda of anti-semitism and the risk
of political suspicion and stood by
David and Amalia visiting them in their
apartment in the heart of the Jewish
section of the city most frequently
mentioned in the letters are Cora's old
school friend Eva and her mother there
he often a maid Amalia writes and in
several letters she notes that they've
just left or if their visits coincide
with the writing of the letter they add
a short greeting sometimes Eva's mother
a good faithful soul David courser comes
by herself
sometimes even comes alone sometimes
they come together Eva a school teacher
was told that if she wanted to advance
in her career she must join the not-see
party
she refused and was not given the
promotions awarded to her more compliant
colleagues another visitor mention in
the letters is a Marie spot if for many
years had been my grandparents live in
made Nazi law prohibited non-jewish
women from working as maids in Jewish
homes but Marie continued to see her
firm or former employers and help them
when she could as late as January 1941
David says that he is very fortunate to
be tirelessly cared for by both Amalia
and Marie particularly satisfying for
David were visits from some of his
favorite non-jewish students the visits
that I received from loyal friends among
them some quite surprising ones are
always a joy but I have been able to win
their extra their esteem has an
extremely healthy effect on my severely
threatened self-esteem and refutes the
derisive old saying that only those in
the gods hate become school teachers
David's most unlikely relationship
however was with a member of the SS
Albert Massa chick the son of a rural
police officer was brought up with the
anti-semitic prejudices common in that
milieu he joined the Hitler Youth at the
age of 16 and by 1936 was one of the
leaders of this then illegal
organization in 1937 he moved on to the
equally illegal SS
the joy with which he greeted the advent
of Nazi rule in Austria however soon
turned to disillusionment party
membership wants a daring adventure now
became a series of highly disciplined
meetings in which orders were handed
down from higher up and obeyed without
question masa checks doubts about Nazism
were increased by a young woman who was
a relative of a former Chancellor of
Germany general Kurt von Schleicher
flaca a conservative military man but no
friend of the Nazis had been murdered by
the SS in 1934 learning of this murder
from someone personally affected by it
opened massive checks eyes to other
abuses six months after the Anschluss he
became part of a resistance group
associated with a Catholic priest Roman
Carl Schultz
who like Master chicks had been a member
of the Nazi Party when it was illegal
masa Czech had studied together with and
become a friend of Friedrich air one of
my grandfather's closest former pupils
who invited him to come along on one of
his visits to his revered former teacher
das master check now in his 20s and
still a member of the SS found himself
in David and emolia's apartment well I
think I'll leave the reading there
they're just samples if you like of some
of the things that are in the book and
I'll be very happy to take questions
from you remember if you could wait for
the microphone to come before you start
speaking thank you yes just wait for the
mic
I was just wondering if your
grandparents unfortunately didn't have
the opportunity to leave was there ever
a consideration of going into hiding as
other Jewish families had done as far as
I can tell there was never any thought
of going into hiding of course you have
to say what evidence do I have well I
have the evidence of the letters my
grandparents wrote to Australia but then
those grant those letters could always
be opened by the Nazis so you wouldn't
really discuss such plans in them the
only other option seems to be that is
hinted at is there is a reference to
something like don't worry about us if
things get too bad we will sleep the
sleep from which there was no awakening
and from my grandmother survived or she
told my aunt I have this from my aunt
they had actually planned to commit
suicide that was another option they
decided not to commit suicide I think
because they they did get good news from
Australia my the birth of their first
grandchild my older sister was something
that they learned about in 1940 when
they were still getting letters and the
marriage of their younger daughter Doris
also and I think my grandmother told my
mother that that news kept them going
their desire to see hopefully to see
their children again kept their going in
terms of being hidden I really don't
know whether anyone even offered them
that possibility you have to remember
that while they knew that they were
going to be deported they didn't have
any idea that they were going to be
murdered or that they ran a great risk
of being murdered my grandfather and
this I think is one of the reasons why
they were not in a rush to leave my
grandfather had fought in the First
World War had been on the front for a
total of two and a half years of the war
he'd been twice wounded he'd been
decorated for his service and he felt
that that was going to protect him
indeed in it did protect him in marginal
ways they were among the last Jews to be
deported from Vienna and when they were
deported they were
not deported to one of the Polish
ghettos like Lodge nor to one of the
death camps they were deported to terezi
and start which was a sort of self run
Jewish ghetto for relatively privileged
Jews but it was incredibly overcrowded
there wasn't enough food hygiene was
terrible
and my grandfather who was a diabetic
died within six months so in a sense yes
he got slightly more favored treatment
but it didn't really help him but I
imagine he thought that yes he was going
to be sent out of Vienna yes it would be
difficult he would have a very
restricted quiet life but I think the
thought perhaps are going into hiding
with a risk that not only he would be
killed if he was discovered but those
who were protecting him would be killed
probably was something he would not have
been prepared to take well you your
subtitle has the word tragedy in it and
our thinking of tragedy as you were
talking and also before when I glanced
through your book in Greek tragedy as
I'm sure you know probably most people
here know there is the question of
self-deception that Oedipus discovers
for example eventually that he was
deceiving himself now this goes all the
way to Aristotle's Poetics
to Freud's realization of people not
being fully aware what's going on and
you grandfather a highly intelligent man
obviously in some ways he was deceiving
himself about his position decorated
veteran as he was and what his fellow
Viennese Hitler was up to and this
question I think goes much deeper than
meets the eye
because the question is and I'm asking
you as well as raising the question now
in college words do you emerge as said
that but a wiser man from looking at it
and realizing what happened
now Herzl when he came when he came to
to Paris to the Dreyfus trial walked out
from his self-delusion the Jews can find
another solution beside the Jewish state
he was a summation as a machinist he
considered converting all the Jerusalem
Christianity but he woke up now some
Jews even today so I am asking you both
a personal question also the professor
didn't wake up that while for the
International academic professional
leaders one world the people can move
ever at Sandersville if they want to
leave for a few weeks there were 20
places they can do it but they're the
less fortunate Jews from Morocco from
Iraq from Iran who whom there is no
other place than Israel and many Jews
are still living in the self-deception
that Israel is something which may be
redundant and I wonder if you see the
connection between you grand fathers
deceiving himself about his position
about the fact which many people did
figure out the Jews are going to be
murdered and the attitude towards Israel
today where many Jews don't want even to
know that Saddam Hussein before the God
first Gulf War
and now he is going to burn first Israel
half of Israel this we cannot do it by
poison you cannot do the chemicals you
can do it by nuclear bomb and that's why
all that have supported him and this and
now a way I think going beyond the
question of us think is still deception
of many Jews looking and not only Jews
looking at what happens then and what's
happening now well thank you for that
question there are many there are many
interesting things wrapped up of course
in what you've said firstly as far as my
grandfather is concerned I think you're
absolutely right to say that there is a
tragedy a personal tragedy based on an
element of self-deception self-deception
in the sense of failing to see the
depths of evil that the Nazis could sink
to could could carry out and for him
that's particularly poignant since as I
point out in the book his connection
with Freud and
was not accidental it was because right
from the beginning right from those very
first letters I have it's clear that his
great interest is in exploring what he
calls the secrets of the human soul in
one of the letters in understanding his
fellow human beings and Adler's
inferiority theory should have given him
a good handle actually on this I mean
you know it's talks about individuals
and he himself in his own writings talks
about literary examples for instance of
individuals who have some sort of sense
of your inferiority and overcompensate
become dominant become violent and so on
and here was this failed artist from the
force to live in you know single men's
home and so on a fairly clear case I
would have thought of for right for
Adlerian analysis and and yet my
grandfather didn't clearly see how far
that could go so yes there is a tragic
deception there then you went further
and link this with Zionism and
anti-semitism and let me just say a
little bit it's not quite an answer to
your question but let me say a little
bit about my grandfather's attitude to
that his attitude was fairly typical
actually of Viennese Jews although
certainly Hadsell was himself a Viennese
Jew he was the classic case of the
Prophet neglected in his own country
Viennese Jews did not rally to Zionism
by and large there were exceptions but
the the call was much more heard further
east and understandably so because
Viennese Jews felt fairly comfortable
they felt assimilated they had equal
rights they did not feel you know
particularly threatened by anti-semitism
although certainly there was
anti-semitism there no no no well
extreme depending on what you call
extreme there were strong very extreme
anti-semitic statements were made there
was some violence at universities by
nationalist student groups but there
were basically not programs as has
happened for the further east so they
did feel relatively safe and also this
was a remark you made about Athens and
Jerusalem I think my grandfather's
values were very much
of the Classical period they were
universalistic values he did not like
any sense of tribalism or nationalism
and he clearly saw Zionism in that light
so he sian ism was basically not
something that that he personally liked
or approved of and in that you could say
given his situation you would have to
say at the time he was wrong the
Zionists who did go to Palestine before
the war obviously saved their lives and
the lives of of their families if they
if they brought them with them now how
do we feel about that today that's a
difficult question I've been fortunate
to grow up in a tolerant multicultural
society in which I have not been
adversely affected by anti-semitism grew
up in Australia and I'm living now in
another multicultural society that also
protects the rights of minorities as you
point out there are many other societies
in which that is not the case and
certainly the existence of somewhere
that they have the right to go is a boon
and a refuge for some of those Jews that
you've mentioned mind you there are many
other refugees who don't happen to be
Jewish
you also need places to go and I think
we ought to encourage countries to take
more refugees for that reason alone but
specifically is a Zionist ideology still
a right one for the world in the 21st
century I find that a difficult question
and but in the end I suppose I don't see
Zionism as a solution it may have been
necessary in its time but it's also
obviously causing immense problems I
mean the the situation of Jews in Israel
is now also a perilous one not perilous
I believe because of Saddam who whatever
powers reaches he had might have had
before 1991 I don't believe has since
then had the capacity to attack either
Israel or the United States in a
his way but certainly perilous from
Palestinian suicide bombers and I think
Jews living in the United States or
Australia well now you know have reason
to feel safer than Jews living in Israel
I think that ultimately the solution can
only come from a state that accepts the
right of non-jews to live together as
equal citizens that looks like it's
going to be a very long time coming
unfortunately at present but I do
believe that that is the most desirable
goal to work towards ultimately further
questions yes I was thinking along the
same lines as that question but I
couldn't have asked it nearly as well
but a couple of things that come up was
us the austro-hungarian Empire a
multicultural society at that time I
mean that's one element do you have any
sense whether you're whether there was a
class or an ideological component to
your grandfather was he a Marxist
sympathizer because he had a lot of good
things going for him in terms of the
Nazis and quite a fair number of Jews
who had those things like having served
in World War one were much better off
than others and I think it's quite good
if you survive another thing so I
wondered if there was an ideological
problem in his background where he was
seen as a Marxist in addition to being a
Jew and also was do you think class was
any element to it in the sense did
non-jewish Austrians who were of equal
prominence come out a lot better because
I have a feeling that there was a severe
leveling effect in in the Nazi era where
people who were in a privileged classes
were brought down a lot I may be wrong
about that so I wondered if you know
anything and by the way I've
disappointed you don't have an index in
the book which would make it easier to
check a few of these things so am I
please write to my publishers on that
all I wanted
they said it wasn't the kind of book
that needed one and I save money by not
putting it in but can you respond well
I'll try and remember the more firstly
was austria-hungary multicultural to a
degree I mean definitely German was well
firstly that for those who don't know
anything about it
austria-hungary was actually a
compromise that was worked out I think
in 1867 between Austria and Hungary
which was seen as the other major
national power so it was it was the
Kaiser Lee and Kearney Glee that means
imperial and royal Kingdom and yeah cow
and car and kekkai Nia as a cow Krauss
call that the satirist which has cakana
has sort of other more you know feces
like overtones perhaps in Germany caca
so yes there was there was in you know
the Emperor was the Emperor of Austria
and and the imperial court in that sense
was was german-speaking but he was also
the king of Hungary and Hungary had its
own Parliament which was Hungarian
speaking and its own Prime Minister who
was also Hungarian speaking and it was
like parallel to the imperial prime
minister who was German speaking the
Balkans and the Czechs and so on and and
they were very multicultural but it's a
complex story there were you know the
Czechs eventually got language rights
but it took longer and I'm not sure
about you the poles and the Ukrainians
in Galicia the and the Balkans they
Croatia was part of the austro-hungarian
Empire and Bosnia Herzegovina was simply
occupied peacefully after I think 1878
as part of the settlement with Russia
after the Crimean War so that was a more
military occupation almost there and
that of course the Sarajevo is where the
assassination of Archduke Franz
Ferdinand occurred so I think it's a
patchwork thing but definitely in Vienna
anyone had the right to travel to Vienna
or live in Vienna and there were a lot
of checks and Hungarians and so it was
pretty cosmopolitan anyway if not full
equal rights for the
various nationalities you asked about my
grandfather's ideological position as
far as I can put it together before 1914
he was politically conservative I gather
that from remarks he makes to the
Freudian circle where he defends he's a
high school teacher remember at the most
academic of the gimnasia that is the
high schools that trained you for
university where you had to learn Greek
and Latin so the most academic of
Vienna's schools he was a high school
teacher and he defended the traditional
systems of discipline against criticism
that they put too much pressure on their
students that was what his paper or part
of the thing about his paper on suicide
in in childhood or in students he was
responding to criticism that it was the
severe discipline of the high school
that causes their students to suicide
and the liberal reformers all wanted to
see this changed and at that time he
defends it somewhat so he's somewhat
actually more conservative than Freud
who comments takes a more middle
position and Freud certainly was no
political radical Freud was also was
politically conservative there's also a
remark one of the historians of the
split it's actually no biographer of
Freud Ernst Jones says tries to paint
the split as about politics as well
idlers friends were all socialists and
and that's why they left right and
hardly himself was a sort of social
democrat there was another clear social
democrat in that group and there were
some connections but in response Adler's
daughter Alexandra Alexandra ala
actually quote is quoted as saying
giving an example up and home was rather
conservative saying ok he doesn't fit
this pattern that Jones is trying to
present of the split as having been
between conservatives and socialists so
up to then he was he was conservative he
also clearly supported the first world
war
some socialists had doubts about
although in the end most of them
supported her - but by the end of the
war there's a remark quoted by someone
in your where he says I'm getting more
more red and presumably that is to be
taken in a political sense although the
person who reported that said maybe he
meant he was getting more and more
embarrassed and ashamed at
austria-hungary's conduct in maintaining
the slaughter basically but it's
consistent with the political
interpretation is consistent with the
fact that my mother and aunt tell me
that they knew him as as a social
democrat in austrian politics the
communists were not a very significant
force in contrast to many other
Europeans European countries it was the
social democrats who were the big party
on the Left mass mark mass party during
all the free elections from 1919 till
1934 they never got less than 40% of the
vote very strong party and they totally
ruled Vienna from 1918 to 1934 and
Vienna was a province as well as just a
city in terms of the election so Vienna
was actually the first major European
city to freely elect a socialist
government and that was the party to
which it seemed after the war my
grandfather belonged so it was kind of
moderate socialism you can think of it
as so Scandinavian type social welfare
state if you like definitely not
communism but I think that's where he
went
politically your last question at least
the last one I remember it was them
yeah about privileged people well no I
think privileged Austrians or Germans
did far better than Jews undoubtedly
there was no plan systematically to
murder them and many of them actually
did extremely well the industrials like
Krupp for example in in Germany
obviously did quite well interesting
example the Vidkun shine family although
of Jewish origin managed to actually get
papers saying that they counted as
Aryans they were not Jewish in terms of
religion anymore because of their wealth
there's in this book Vicki in Stein's
poker there's interesting discussion of
how this was bought off for a vast
amount of gold that was paid to the
Nazis
so they survived they all survived the
war living in Nazi Germany
they're doing that because I really
didn't have the money he wasn't a
wealthy person he was a high school
teacher he had no substantial but he was
not there's a phrase that somebody
Goering says I decide who is a German I
don't know if you ever heard that phrase
but it was apparently possible to guess
as I'm prompted it was kal Louisa who
was the anti-semitic mayor of Vienna
around the turn of the century who said
that although the Nazi certainly had
some of that ideology and you concede in
the case of the Vidkun Stein's who
definitely had they been poor would have
been classified as Jews under the
Nuremberg Laws but were able to buy it
off but I think there were very rare and
very extreme cases generally you
couldn't but but on the whole I mean you
think about you know my my grandfather
students for example who went to this
very academic high school the non-jewish
ones they generally survived they were
relatively privileged they had to serve
in the army most of them of course but
those that you know some of them got
killed on the Eastern Front but they
generally survived and held some of them
held influential positions in in
post-war Austria yes lady in the bank
interest in the title or the subtitle
actually my grandfather and the tragedy
of Jewish Vienna not only in the
historic past but I'm curious if you
could respond to something I had the
privilege of working with be no visa
baron at Boston University who I don't
know if you're familiar with him he was
the Israeli cultural attache to the UN
and he was probably one of the people
responsible for Israel's survival and
existence
he pulled the South American states at
the time of the 1949 partition vote to
make sure that they either voted for
Israel or abstained if they had a
negative contingent in their party and
it's largely a court according to
several people it's largely based on his
work that the vote went the way it did
he was also very firmly involved in
scientism and he's actually up until
last year when he retired he was
teaching at BU as the oldest professor
at BU he's now I think 88 but one of the
things that he says in his book
professions of a of a lucky Jew were was
the fact that as he's returned to Vienna
in
last ten or twenty years it has seemed
to him as though one of the tragedies
that's been a longer standing one has
been the fact that Jews felt so betrayed
by the community that was Vienna that
they've not returned and he sees in this
he was very active in the cabaret scene
on his wife as an actress and he sees in
that now a loss of the cultural depth
and texture that was there at the time
of the first and second world wars and I
wonder if you could comment on that as
well as is that something you've also
perceived I have I've never lived in
Vienna but I have been there many times
and spent I guess you know if you add
them up a reasonable amount of time
there yes there is starting to be a
Jewish community again in Vienna but
it's not at all the people who are
thrown out all their descendants it's
not people like me it's almost
exclusively Eastern European Jews who
have come there Vienna was a conduit for
many Eastern European Jews who were
allowed out of the Soviet bloc and some
of them stayed there and it's them and
their children and some others who've
come more recently so the cultural
ferment that was stimulated by a large
Jewish population has not been recreated
and in fact Friedrich air whom I
mentioned is one of the non-jewish
students of my grandfather who visited
my grandfather during those days later
became an important writer and cultural
critic in Austria and he wrote that
himself in fact he wrote an essay which
he dedicated to my grandfather which was
called Austria and Judaism and really
was about the significance of the Jewish
contribution to Vienna's cultural life
before the war and the fact that that
had now been lost so yes I think it has
been asked I mean I guess if you ask
well why didn't they go back I can think
about my own case on my own parents why
didn't my parents go back I think they
didn't go back because the Vienna that
they knew had been destroyed all the
people that they knew all their friends
and family had either managed to get out
and emigrated and some were here in the
United States some were in Australia
some were in Argentina or wherever they
were scattered or else they'd been
killed and so it would have had you know
not have any of the resonance that it
had before it took them a long time
before they could even visit but towards
the end of the 1950's they did go back
and they did make contact they kept in
contact as I say with a few of these
people who've been good to their
grandparents they'd written and so they
were delighted to see them and they you
know but they had very ambivalent
feelings when they went back they they
loved the beauty of the city it is still
a very beautiful city that preserves a
lot of that of its greatest days but of
the human element there was this huge
gap there's a question down the frontier
yes just wait for the microphone to
arrive how did your grandmother get away
my grandmother did not get away she was
deported with my grandfather to terezi
instead she survived the entire war from
1942 to liberation in tourism start you
might say what were the odds of doing
that I've looked at the figures about a
hundred and seventy thousand Jews were
sent to tourism start about 17,000
survived so it was one in ten chance of
survival of those who died a substantial
part maybe 40,000 died interesting start
like my grandfather from the lack of
food and poor hygiene and the remainder
were shipped East but mostly to
Auschwitz so to survive you had to have
firstly I guess a good Constitution good
stamina and secondly you had to be
fortunate in not being shipped onwards
now one thing that I discussed at the
end of the book is my grandmother worked
in the central administration of tourism
start it was as I said it was a ghetto
in which there was a kind of you could
say a Sherrod but to some extent it was
more than a Sherrod of Jewish self-rule
that is there was a jewish council of
elders and a jewish administration the
nazis did not administer at the camp in
detail they said you know this is the
food that you've got you distributed
this is what else you got and so on and
then they would say and now we need
5,000 young men to
labor in the East or something and they
would either use them as laborers or
kill them and then they would say we
need to remove 5000 older people and you
know so they would say the categories
that they wanted to deport but the
internal administration they did leave
to the Jews though occasionally if the
council they didn't like then I think it
happened twice during a period they
would actually deport the entire council
kill them and set up a new council but
one possibility is that by being in the
administration that my grandmother had
some kind of protection so I'm sort of
in to make sure that she didn't herself
get deported and if you read the
accounts of survivors memoirs and so on
that was very often effective being in
the protection of some influential
person who could determine whether your
card got placed in the group of those
who were being transported on or not you
know that raises many interesting
questions I guess about how one would
behave in those circumstances a comment
about the resident stat which you may
know but may be that people may not know
it there was a film made by the Nazis
the Fuhrer do you deny - that the leader
meaning Hitler gives the Jews a city it
was used for propaganda purposes and
with collusion known and unknown by the
European Red Cross which was Swiss
German Nazi collaboration in which there
were Red Cross visits in which it was
shown the Jews are living nicely in
Terezin stat and before arrival I think
there was at least one or maybe several
arrivals over that cross there was a
removal of all the people who didn't
look health and well to Auschwitz and
the others put on shows and our trend
stuff like that to show how well the
Jews are being treated I think this
needs to be said about the res instead
because it was specially kept in better
condition as a propaganda showpiece I
think that I mean you're right I think
it was only specially kept that way for
a relatively brief period as you say
before before the inspections came and
then afterwards all of this stuff was
dismantled and taken away yes yes I I
wondered if looking at your grandparents
lives and the fates that they met led
you to re-examine some of your own issue
positions on biomedical or bioethical
issues well not specifically I mean
obviously I've thought about this I mean
the argument I sometimes made against
positions that I hold that they open up
a kind of a slippery slope that by not
respecting the sanctity of human life in
all cases for instance because I'm a
supporter of euthanasia in various
circumstances that could not open up the
way for something like this again
obviously I've thought about that
objection even before I started thinking
about writing about my grandfather right
because of my background I I had to take
that objection seriously but I think
what's really crucial to understanding
what happened was the idea that the
individual doesn't matter in the in the
totalitarian system that the individual
is sacrificed to some more abstract
concept like the state or the fault the
purity of the race something of that
sort and yet what I'm talking about
really is very much the opposite the
idea of euthanasia in the interests of
the individual and the case of voluntary
euthanasia the person who respecting the
wishes of the person who wants to die
otherwise of the parents or they need to
make a decision for example for a
newborn with a severe disability so I
think that these are important
distinctions and that what we need to do
is to guard against if you like the
totalitarian mentality of not thinking
that individuals are important rather
than trying to whole lines which i think
of already because of modern medical
technology become very thin very
artificial lines between what we may and
may not do when we wield so much medical
technology that we are inevitably making
life-and-death decisions
I can just follow up on that a little
bit advocates of animal rights are often
criticized that they're more concerned
with the suffering of animals and they
are with the suffering of humans how do
you reconcile say being concerned with
the animals on factory farms does that
trivialize or somehow slights a victims
of the Holocaust firstly I think the
accusation is completely false I don't
think that people in the animal rights
movement are more concerned about
animals than about humans I think
they're concerned about both and rightly
so and indeed if you look at the history
of humane reform movements you often
find a strong overlap between the two so
that it's not a coincidence I think that
it was the leaders of the anti-slavery
society who helped to stop the British
slave trade who were also many of them
among the founders of what later became
the Royal Society for the Prevention of
Cruelty to Animals and you find the same
sort of thing happening in the United
States so I think it's often a general
feeling of compassion of desire to stop
unnecessary suffering in terms of you
know is that a trivializing of the
Holocaust to be concerned about animals
in factory farms no I don't think so I
think that we should be concerned about
suffering we should not say simply
they're animals so their suffering
doesn't matter
I don't compare the two I am made
uncomfortable by comparisons the two you
may have noticed this a website at the
moment called a mass killing which does
explicitly well it doesn't exactly
equate would be wrong to say it equates
but it does refer to the mentality of
the mass killing of animals somewhat
hidden away in factory farms and
slaughterhouses and refer to the
mentality of the Nazis in the Holocaust
I can understand why some people in the
animal movement see those parallels but
I have to say I don't like them I'm not
comfortable with them and I think there
is too much of a danger that people will
take them as in some way ik waiting the
to which I
never do okay pushing time away is
published by HarperCollins visit
HarperCollins dot-com for more
information